en
magasinant les fruits et légumes au
marché public de sainte foy à québec que
dominique anglade veut illustrer une
contradiction
l'inflation pénalise les québécois
tandis qu'elle procède au gouvernement
pendant que les coffres du gouvernement
legault se remplissent les poches des
québécois se vide pour les aider une
fois élu dominé caen de la promet 4
milliards de dollars en mesures elles
bonifierait de 25 % le crédit d'impôt
pour solidarité
abolirait la tvq sur les produits de
première nécessité comme du savon et les
québécois n'en perdrait pas non plus sur
les premiers 4000 $ de leur facture
d'électricité
d'ailleurs elle gèlerait les taris
environ un an c'est 5000 dollars dans la
poche de votre famille elle choisit de
faire cette annonce dans la capitale
nationale qui ne comptent plus de député
libéral et en l'absence de ces candidats
économique est ce que vous avez perdu
votre site de partout l'économie vous
essayez de le regagner pourquoi
aucunement perdu 7 suzuka au contraire
alors que les libéraux s'engagent à
redonner 1125 dollars par année aux
contribuables en diminuant les impôts
d'un point 5 % pour les deux paliers
d'imposition françois legault renchérit
avec une promesse similaire sauf que
l'huile et diminuerait 2% dès 2023 qui
signifie 630 dollars d'économies pour
quelqu'un qui gagne un salaire de 80
milles par année on ne faut pas avec un
gros moment de la caq retourner à
l'austérité
libéral c'est une approche équilibrée
prudentes et responsables pour financer
la baisse d'impôts de 2 milliards de
dollars par année qualifiée d'
historique
il réduira les contributions au fonds
des générations dont l'objectif est de
réduire la dette on est des
conservateurs fiscaux éric duhaime
rappelle qu'il a proposé bien avant eux
de ne pas payer d'impôts sur les
premiers 20 mille dollars gagny plutôt
que les quinze mille premiers comme
c'est le cas actuellement il le
financera entre autres en permettant
l'exploitation des hydrocarbures au
québec pour nous une source de revenus
supplémentaire qui va apparaître dans
notre cadre financier
la surenchère s'est poursuivie plus tard
dans la journée françois legault a
annoncé le montant du deuxième chèque
envoyé à plus de 6 millions de québécois
depuis la fin de l'année entre 400 et
600 dollars selon le revenu c'est
important d'aider les québécois c'est
important de faire face à l'inflation
reste à savoir ses promesses va
s'effectuer au port il serait même
baisser la taxe tout court sur les
achats confesse je pense
les chefs de partis ont sondé leurs
troupes avant de partir en campagne
électorale
diminuer le coût de la vie s'avère la
priorité d'une majorité de québécois
mais plusieurs demandent à être
convaincu que l'argent promis ira bel et
bien dans leur poche